let's bring in Congressman uh from Texas
in his in the El Paso area of course
Uvalde Congressman Tony Gonzalez a
republican Congressman how disappointed
are you that when the president saw you
at Uvalde he said to you said to him
let's talk about the Border he says I
will Tony but yet when you reached out
to the White House what did they say
about this visit
yeah they they told me that I couldn't
attend and the the president essentially
lied to my face and this shouldn't
surprise anyone and I think it's
important that we have Republicans that
are constantly pushing the
administration to go no no no I want to
work with you I want to find Solutions
there they want all Republicans to just
give up but this wasn't this wasn't
about solving problems this was a
partisan trip that was just made as a
photo op you know it took it took the
president 80 years to get to the Border
I I suspect it's going to take another
80 80 years before he comes back uh
clearly this shows the Administration
has zero interest in solving this they
think it's a political problem they
don't think it's a policy problem those
the videos that I shared a few weeks ago
highlight this isn't a political problem
Bush uh Obama uh Clinton Trump certainly
never had problems like this this is a
policy issue well it's it's interesting
congresswoman because he didn't do it in
his first two years as president he did
it as he probably is about to announce
that he's running for re-election in
2024. so essentially he needed a photo
op to check the box to say look the
Republicans are complaining about it so
I went down to our Southern border I saw
with my own two eyes and what he said
yesterday Congressman was he said the
system is broken and Congress needs to
act so he's putting the ball in the
House Republicans court but whatever you
guys come up with he's not going to like
and neither is the Senate
that's exactly right I mean it's it's uh
it's politics 101 always blame somebody
else for everything that's wrong you
know the other part of this story too is
is he's in Mexico today what is that
conversation going to be like is it is
it going to talk about woke programs is
he going to talk about climate change
yes or is he going to talk about this
cartel uh uh war that is happening in
Sinaloa you know there was just a major
uh prison outbreak there in Juarez
across from El Paso people that I
represent along the border we do not
feel safe so you know there's a lot to
this story but it highlights the fact
that turns out the administration never
wanted to work with Republicans
shouldn't surprise anyone but it's good
to finally see them get exposed
Congressman I know you said over the
weekend that you don't plan to support
the rules package in the house because
of a possible cut in defense spending I
know you represent South Texas there are
a lot of military hospitals and bases
and posts in that area also Nancy May
said she's worried about the back room
deals we interviewed the majority web
and he said he believes that you and
Nancy Mace will come around listen to
this
the rules which has not been widely
reported literally are the rules that
our conference voted on after the
election with one exception and that is
the motion to vacate is being restored
to where it was for a hundred years
before Nancy Pelosi changed it Tony has
said he's not willing to vote for them
yet Nancy on the other hand has said
she's on the fence I I do believe both
Tony and Nancy will come around tonight
when they realize the things that they
want to talk about are in this separate
agreement
he said you're not willing yet if that's
true what will it take
yeah no I appreciate uh whip ember's uh
leadership and and this is only the
beginning you know these are the easy
part you know the the speaker vote and
and the rules vote but I guarantee you
nobody expected 15 rounds of voting when
we discussed hey what are some things
that we're going to be able to take no
one said okay it's going to be four days
15 rounds of voting and your families
are going to be run through the wringer
also you know as bad as it was to watch
it it was even worse to be part of it
who wants to see this this uh uh Fiasco
get played out over and over again so
I'm against the rule for the rules for a
couple different reasons one is is the
defense spend the defend the cut and
defense yeah I think that's absolutely
terrible idea but the other is to vacate
the chair I mean I don't want to see us
oh every two months be in lockdown this
isn't the parliament I mean the American
public are counting on House Republicans
to be the the one savior in this all if
we can't get this right it's going to be
it's going to be a nightmare after
nightmare Nancy May said that uh that
Matt Gates is a total fraud do you feel
that way
you know I don't like
my colleagues you know look there's
there
people in Congress and it's very
frustrating to serve with these people
but that's across the Spectrum I look at
it Whatever happened yesterday happened
yesterday how do we go forward and
honestly this rules package vote isn't
just about the rules it's what does next
week look like what does next month look
like and you know what I do think
there's an opportunity in the house for
Rank and file members to lead and I
think that's what it's going to take you
know it's time for us to go take back
the house take back this country we have
all these different factions I get that
but we have to represent the American
people yep and it starts today
Congressman thanks for starting your
Monday with fox and friends thank you
and being so candid because it was
agonizing to watch and for your service
he was in the Navy indeed I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis